c'était il ya un an des usagers du tcsp
heureux pour ce lancement tant de fois
reportée
l'incendié ça depuis longtemps ah oui
avant longtemps la gêne quand tu n'as
voilà même papier elle est décédée
oui mais c'est vrai la mercière
j'aboutis alors au nom après quel est le
niveau de satisfaction des usagers et le
transport tant espéré at il finalement
répondu à toutes les attentes
on dit maman n'ont mangé danard birmanie
alors après secteur nokia les adam
nouvelles du bois pis si cela ne passe
et on roule on a une route qui est libre
on apprend ne prend pas d'embouteillage
donc on est toujours à l'euro par
rapport à ça voilà voilà
et je suis satisfait dans l'ensemble ça
va
ça convient largement au niveau des
autres je trouve
ce qu'on attend pas trop haut niveau
tout et c'est ce faire lui même n'entend
pas trop si bien desservi si la plupart
des utilisateurs semblent conquis
d'autres émettent quelques réserves sur
le service comme sur les passagers et je
vais voyage noté sp
il ne passe pas le ticket alors pourquoi
les gens sachent que nous avons une
entreprise qui reste stable après tt s p
et à l'entretien de la voiture
le nettoyage des plus il est assez
souvent on ressent c'est du sens coup il
y a beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
fabrication du tcsp
mais je pense qu'ils auraient dû mettre
plus en manche et voilà on n'a pas
suffisamment il n'y en a pas
suffisamment cause autre bémol
l'harmonisation du réseau si la
fréquence des bus à haut niveau de
service reste satisfaisante
ce n'est pas toujours le cas pour les
lignes de bus classique tout noté sp oui
mais les bus depuis 9h30
j'attends bus je ne vois pas de
fonctionner en même temps
un an après sur la route la cohabitation
avec les autres usagers reste compliquée
hier soir un accident entre un bhns et
une voiture a fait cinq blessés légers
au giratoire de ker 10 il faut dire que
les voies dédiées sont utilisés par tout
type de véhicules quant à la
signalisation
elle n'est pas toujours respectée quand
elle n'est pas tout simplement hors
service